jellyfish look like they're flying  through the water but could something  fly like a jellyfish in the air  to answer this question researchers  built and tested a flying robotic  jellyfish the tiny bot flies by flapping  two of its wings at a time built of  lightweight materials like mylar and  carbon fiber it only weighs about 2  grams inside the delicate frame a  miniscule motor turns a crankshaft  flapping the wings it can change  directions and even hover by altering  its flapping pattern once free of their  tethers small hovering craft like these  could be used to monitor conditions in  the air or even for surveillance  you